[Music]
you can hear the
the word weird very often you referred
to to quantum
mechanics with the word weird quite
often and and that brings me back to
your
example of uh that you mentioned earlier
reading as cat i mean first of all i'm
very very happy
that you mentioned uh that you're not
actually doing
experiments like that with cats that it
is a thought experiment
uh and i'm sure everyone has heard about
it probably even watched little videos
or sketches they've been around for a
while
but nevertheless it is still very very
confusing
uh please continue and explain to us in
layman's terms
what's this thought experiment about
what does it tell us
the schrodinger cut is is a thought
experiment
that illustrates one
of the very uh particular properties of
quantum mechanics is that the actual
state of a system
can be thought as being in a
superposition of states
and each of these states correspond to
a different specific outcome
and for example in the case of the
schrodinger cat
the two states have the outcome the cat
is dead or the cat is alive
now if we think of a physical system
like an electron or like an atom a
physical system
of an atomic scale the
the states have
uh outcomes that correspond to the
values
of a physical property
that can be energy that can be
angular momentum that can be spin that
is
also an angular momentum so
in quantum mechanics a system can be
in a superposition of several states
so it can be simultaneously
in a superposition of state that
correspond to several
outcome and therefore there will not be
a definite outcome until
a measurement is made so
if i come back to the cat it means that
the cat
is simultaneously dead or alive
until i try to measure this four cut
so as soon as the observer steps in as
soon as the observer steps in
then it is just the moment you can't
have all the different layers of
superposition as an observer
it is just the moment you actually catch
in that moment
that's what you refer to with
measurement exactly and
and this way of measuring
uh is also specific of quantum mechanics
and so
if i do a single measurement
on a system that is in a superposition
of state
as you rightly said i will get one of
the possible
outcome that are associated with the
many state that can be present
in the superposition and then the cat
will be
either alive or dead but
i can repeat the experiment and so
at each measurement that i will make
on the same superposition of state i can
get
one of the specific outcome of
one state the state that has been
realized
at the time i made the experiment and so
it means that i will
measure the same outcome a certain
number of times if i repeat
the experiment and the number of time
that i
measure that outcome is given by the
weight of the corresponding state
in the superposition so think
of a system that is in a superposition
of two states
it means that if i do a large enough
number of measurement i will measure
each
outcome with a 50
probability and it's exactly like
tossing
a coin that is of course unbiased
otherwise i will not get
a half probability and so
this way of understanding how the
measurement is made
has has a name in quantum mechanics it
is called the probabilistic
interpretation of the measurement it is
the
most widely accepted interpretation
and again it has been verified by
all the experiments that have been set
up
to test this prediction up to now
but it was not accepted by every
scientist
since it has been proposed for example
einstein strongly objected to this
interpretation
and he said uh it's a very famous quote
of einstein
that god does not play dies
by by which it means that he refused
this
interpretation is he right or wrong i
mean quantum physics as we've now
understood it and certainly this
the concept of superposition seems to
contradict einstein
yes and so up to now
this probabilistic interpretation
uh stood the test of time like most of
the prediction of quantum mechanics or
all the prediction of quantum mechanics
actually
um so there are other interpretations
of the measurement of a superposition of
states
and one that is the often discussed and
one that is the
the most common is the interpretation of
the parallel worlds
in this interpretation it is
stated that once the outcome
has been measured the system
that results for the measurement and the
observer
evolve separately in time
and follow their own history and so in
this interpretation
each outcome follows a different history
and evolves differently
in time after the measurement and this
is why
this interpretation is known that of the
parallel worlds
there is no experimental evidence that
supports this interpretation to now but
who knows right science reserves
surprises
there could be more professor remarkals
and more monica jones's and more
everyone around all in parallel worlds
yes it's one possibility well
from what i understand these parallel
worlds also
if there was another version of you then
that other version
probably now wouldn't wear a yellow
jumper but maybe a red jumper or or a
coat
or to put it uh sort of more scientific
in this parallel version there could be
an
apple and at the same time an orange or
you could have
zero and at the same time one so all of
this is is very
very confusing ultimately and it leads
me to another
uh sort of thought experiment uh which
is this
famous cloud that supposedly can go
through a wall
um if it can be here and there at the
same time
again from a physical point of view is
that possible
is that what's what's happening uh
indeed so this is what's happening
at least again at the atomic scale so
this experiment uh ref uh
refers to another very important
consequence
of uh the fact that at the
atomic scale or in quantum physics um
of particles can also be a wave and this
imposes that uh you cannot precisely
localize a quantum object coming back to
the the wall so it means that if you are
throwing a quantum particle uh to a wall
depending of
on its energy it can be reflected
or it can go through the wall
and this is of course completely
different from the behavior of a
classical
particle because if you are throwing to
the wall a classical particle it
can be reflected if it doesn't have
enough energy but if you throw it and it
has enough energy it will go
over the wall quantum mechanics even if
it doesn't have enough energy
it can be transmitted through the wall
now if you want to come back to
the precise atomic nature of the cloud
the cloud is made of molecules of
water molecules and so to each water
molecule you can associate the
wavelength
that is inversionally proportional to
its mass and to its velocity
and therefore depending on the thickness
and on the height of the wall
the water molecule can be localized on
one side of the wall inside the wall or
on the other side of the wall but what
is possible for
a water molecule is not possible for me
because again my mass is so much bigger
that i will not have a very
long wavelength i have a very small
wavelength that is associated with me
and therefore i am not very delocalized
and so there is no way
that i could be delocalized on the other
side
of the wall now it it it sounds very
weird but there are again a lot of
technological application that
are precisely exploiting this tunneling
effect that is typical
of quantum mechanics and tunneling
effect is used in transistors but it is
also used
to develop special kind of
microscopy a kind of microscopy that is
called tunneling scanning
microscopy and this microscopy allows to
image
surfaces at the atomic scale and also to
image
for example if you deposit a molecule on
the surface
and this is a very important instrument
for all
the high precision that we need at the
atomic scale to build
a quantum device so tunneling effect
is very important you've you've given us
examples already
the kind of applications that can arise
from from quantum physics and i think
for us not to get completely lost
however exciting
all the technicalities and the science
is it would be helpful to find out
more applications to have more examples
of how we can actually experience and
use
the properties of quantum physics in our
lives
the one that are really present in our
lives
were developed some years ago right it
takes always time before
a new application comes to everyday life
and so we we talked about the the laser
right the the lasing effect which is
really exploiting the discreteness of
energy of photon the discreteness
of energy in in
atoms to get
in in specific cases an amplification of
the emission of photon by
by the atom that has this very
particular property that it is
mono-energetic and so this aspect of
getting a source of
of photon that is monoenergetic is
exploited
in all the spectroscopic techniques
actually that
we use right to identify compound to
to characterize them to understand if
they are a biological molecule in the
out
out out there in space but also
in medicine and so a lot of imaging
techniques exploit
the laser or exploit properties
discreteness of energy level
in atoms in and or
the the spin of nuclei so for example
the the imaging technique that is called
mri magnetic resonance imaging
relies on the two state of spin of of
certain kind of nuclei to to get an
image
by the way the the laser when it was
invented
in 1950 was declared the lab curiosity
nobody cared about it and so you see
also how
right in science it is not always clear
what will be
really useful or not or what will become
a practical
of practical use another aspect is the
electron microscope which was invented
in the
1960s this allowed to
to get a better resolution in space
because it used the wavelengths
associated to a beam of electron
and using this tool it became possible
to see
organic inside the cell and so this led
to
a lot of progress in biology because it
was possible
to to go to develop cellular
biology and nowadays with all the waste
based on quantum mechanics that
became possible we go to molecular
biology right we try to
image molecules uh not only
organic inside the cell so these are
examples that
are part of our day-to-day life
you